hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema ende der
luftbrücke dass deutschland seine
afghanischen ortskräfte im stich nur
noch wenige wochen nur noch wenige tage
entschuldigung also nur noch eine woche
um genau zu sein so lange wollen die usa
mit ihren truppen noch die luftbrücke
aus kabul aufrechterhalten das bedeutet
für die deutsche bundeswehr geht es wohl
noch ein wenig früher raus und es gibt
also jetzt nur noch ein sehr kurzes
zeitfenster um die evakuierungsflüge aus
kabul zu fliegen und wie viele es in
dieser zeit noch raus schaffen können
und wäre es nicht schaffen wird darüber
wollen wir heute sprechen das ist heute
thema und wenn ihr fragen habt dann
stellt sie gerne jederzeit im stream
oder auch an die e-mailadresse die wir
jetzt einblenden und wir wollen heute
sprechen unter anderem mit unserer
reporterin katrin eigendorf sie ist in
taschkent in usbekistan für uns live vor
ort und hat kontakt zu menschen die noch
in kabul festsetzen und wir wollen
außerdem sprechen mit dr schirach assisi
er ist architekt pendelt seit
jahrzehnten zwischen afghanistan und
deutschland und war eben noch vor einer
woche in kabul und hat es gerade so raus
geschafft schönen guten abend hallo
herr assisi zunächst die frage an sie
wer hat ihnen geholfen wie hat das für
sie geklappt herauszukommen aus kabul
sie hasst bedanke mich ich möchte sie
mir die möglichkeit gegeben über die
ecken sind carol und verlauf ihrer
karriere zu sprechen
also das war so tust ich versuche mich
kurz zu fassen das paar sonntag und
samstag und sonntag der 14 funktioniert
das in kabul auf einmal der e mail von
kabul voll mit amerikanische
hubschrauber war wo wir nicht wussten
was überhaupt los ist kein mensch hat
damit gerechnet dass die in zwei drei
tagen taliban die stadt erobern also wir
wussten überhaupt nicht aber dann
menschen gesagt dass die hubschrauber
die amerikanische landsleute aus dem
gelände der botschaft ihrer kunden zu
flughafen liegen unter normal ist das
wird man als deutscher in kabul ist muss
man sich auf einer liste bei der
botschaft eintragen lassen dass es
krisen liste oder elefanten punkt.de in
krisenfall wird man angerufen ich habe
sofort versucht mit unserer botschaft in
kontakt zu kommen aber leider
bekam ich eine ansage die botschaft ist
geschlossen und wir können ihnen nicht
helfen gut dann habe ich versucht mit
auswärtigen amt in kontakt zu kommen
bissigkeit in nummer bekommen aber über
meine frau die in deutschland lebt hat
mir die nummer geschickt dann habe ich
mal versucht diese nummer anzurufen ich
habe diese nummer angerufen glauben sie
mir werden um mich in die umgebung
schüsse fielen und mein leben in gefahr
war ich habe 14 minuten eine werbung
über mit 19 toren müsse und dann
informationen über die risikoländer und
dann nach 30 minuten war ich verbunden
wurden mehr gesagt ich werde weiter
geleitet und dann war eine dame aus dem
außenministerium als erste frage
gestellt hat meinte warum sind sie nach
kabul gekommen ich habe sagt jetzt
erhöhten sie auch mit vorwürfe mein
leben ist in gefahr sie sagen mir die
sie mir helfen können meinte aber auch
wenn wir ihnen eltern ist auf eigene
gefahr sie müssen selber zum flughafen
gehen am liebsten
rate ich ihnen ein paar wochen in kabul
zu bleiben und das land nicht zu
verlassen habe ich ein kleid das mache
ich nicht mein leben ist in gefahr ich
biss einen deutschen personalausweis und
will ich damit die erwischt werke weiß
man nicht was man mit mehr machen und
dann meinte arbeit dann muss sie jetzt
bestätigen bin ich sie evakuiert dann
müsste sie einen flughafen flugzeug
saale die evakuierung ich habe sagt
verdammt noch mal ist sie auf es geht
nicht um die bezahlung nicht bezahle
alles weil sie machen nicht machen
meinte dann wollten sie und verlassen
sie das haus nicht gut ich habe bis mo
bis die akkus gefasst gewartet und am
dienstag
habe ich ein lageplan bekommen da
standort geht
militärische teil der flughafen am edt
karsai not geht muss ich hingehen auf
eigene verantwortung die nehmen für mich
keine verantwortung mehr wurde mehr war
nicht anders also ich musste einen tag
in ich bin mit meiner sekretärin mein
fahrer einfach hingefahren an checkpoint
von taliban folge vorbeigefahren gott
sei dank an dient das waren die ärzte
zwei tage die haben mich überhaupt nicht
kontrolliert ist bissig zum nordkap als
ich da die menschenmenge gesehen habe
ich keine hoffnung mehr gehabt ich habe
gesagt es ist unmöglich das zu schaffen
einfach über diese wie haben die das tor
geschlossen und dann mussten diese mauer
musste da ist eine mama von meter da
musste man über die mauer klettern das
war unmöglich dass erst einmal habe ich
versucht bin ich hingefahren und dann
das ging nicht und dann haben die
angefangen mit scharfem und mit schafe
direkte schüsse rauchbomben
feuerwerkskörper die verbrennen versagt
ich wurde mit feuerwerkskörper am bein
und am rücken getroffen und dann
bewusstlos und und am schlimmsten war
eine frau nebenwerten ich mich gebeugt
habe dieser brauch wurde angeschossen an
körper in der nähe von ihren ohren und
ich sie gefallen und jetzt sage ich der
geschossen
naja
darüber wer geschossen hat lassen sie
uns dann zugleich kommen lassen sie uns
jetzt vorher noch ganz kurz bei meiner
kollegin katrin eigendorf nachfragen ab
wie sich die situation jetzt in den
letzten tagen auch noch mal verschärft
hat vor ort katrin du hast kontakt zu
vielen menschen dort wie ist die lage in
kabul gerade
nun den menschen ist natürlich
mittlerweile bewusst geworden dass das
zeitfenster immer geringer wird es ist
klar die amerikaner werden bis zum 31
august nur noch den flughafen sichern
das bedeutet natürlich dass sie auch
vorher schon abziehen denn sie müssen ja
ihre eigenen leute auch dort wegholen
das heißt man kann davon ausgehen dass
eigentlich ist nur noch um wenige tage
geht die leute herauszuholen sind und
jetzt versucht natürlich jeder noch in
diesen flughafen zu kommen ich bin mit
vielen menschen in kabul in kontakt die
versuchen noch auf liga zu kommen und
nach wie vor ist das große problem an
den flughafen ranzukommen und dann im
flughafen eben an das richtige tor an
den richtigen soldaten
das ist besonders für die ein problem
die sich nach deutschland evakuieren
lassen wollen weil es scheint immer noch
probleme damit zu geben dass deutsche
soldaten leute am tor im empfang nehmen
ich bin auch in kontakt mit
verschiedenen organisationen die leute
hin transportieren zum flughafen also
sicheres geleit garantieren auch das
funktioniert nicht immer sicher man ist
darauf angewiesen da mit den taliban
auch zu kooperieren und die haben ja nun
gestern ziemlich klar gemacht dass sie
es nicht dulden werden dass massenhaft
afghanische staatsbürger jetzt das land
verlassen das heißt die lage spitzt sich
jetzt dramatisch zu vor allem für die
afghanen die ihr land verlassen wollen
wir wollen gleich darüber noch weiter
sprechen mit dr chassis der es geschafft
hat als einer raus aus kabul und mit
unserer reporterin katrin eigendorf
zuvor waren wir zusammen uns einen film
angucken von tim kröger über die
aktuelle lage vor ort in kabul in
afghanistan
diskussionen am flughafen von kabul
menschen zeigen papiere vor versuchen
weiterzukommen irgendwie die bilder
ähneln sich aber die situation wird
immer dramatischer in der afghanischen
hauptstadt denn die zeit läuft aus viele
menschen haben dokumente dabei die
belegen sollen dass sie zur ausreise
berechtigt sind verzweifelt harren sie
kniet im dreckigen brackwasser vor der
flughafen mauer aus
meine botschaft ein die die keine
dokumente haben bitte konnten nicht zum
flughafen die mit pässen dieser oder
greencard sind hier die anderen sollen
gehen sonst kommen die mit berechtigung
nicht durch
seit dem g7 gipfel gestern ist klar dass
die militärisch gesicherte
rettungsaktion am 31 august zu ende geht
spätestens bis dahin ziehen die
amerikaner ihre truppen ab einige länder
werden ihre rettungsaktion wohl schon
früher einstellen es bleiben nur noch
wenige tage
im moment sind hier im plan um am 31
august fertig zu sein um so ihr wir
fertig sind desto besser mit jedem tag
steigt das risiko für unsere truppen
die us luftwaffenbasis im deutschen
ramstein diese menschen haben es
geschafft noch aber ist unklar wieviele
in afghanistan zurück bleiben
der scc sie haben darüber gesprochen
zuvor sie sind mit ihrer sekretärin
zusammen an den flughafen gegangen
stichwort menschen die zurückbleiben
müssen haben sie diese sekretärin
mitgenommen wen haben sie zurückgelassen
als sie aus kabul weggeflogen sind meine
sekretärin verletzt zurückgelassen ihr
mann war beim militär wurde auch
verschwunden und sie ist im moment
versteckt mit jedem sohn habe ich kann
leider ihr nicht helfen weil die
afghanischer staatsangehörigkeit hat ich
habe an allen stellen mich gewendet dass
er in durch das büro gearbeitet da die
erleben ist in gefahr wenig sind wir
zwei drei monaten sie rausholen und die
lage sich beruhigt wieder zu gehen aber
keiner hat mir gern wort meinte ich habe
keine antwort an das ministerium habe
ich mich gewendet und überall aber ich
die antwort habe ich bis es nicht
gekommen
sie haben das jetzt schon sehr
eindrücklich beschrieben her als sie das
da also von seiten der hilfe die sie
eingefordert haben oder noch der sie
gefragt haben nicht viel kam darin wie
es da deine einschätzung jetzt ist
bleiben nur noch wenige tage die
menschen mit denen du kontakt hast vor
ort gibt es für die irgendeine hoffnung
dass denen jetzt noch geholfen wird auf
dem weg zum flughafen der so
beschwerlich ist
ja also ich kann mal von einem positiven
fall berichten wir haben ja für das zdf
in einer
reportage eine junge sportlerin
über monate begleitet die sich dafür
engagiert hat dass frauen in afghanistan
sport treiben können die auch ohne
kopftuch vor der kamera aufgetreten ist
die sich selber als vorbild für frauen
in afghanistan gesehen hat die hat mich
in den letzten tagen ganz oft traurig
und panisch angerufen teilweise sich vom
flughafen gemeldet die hat drei tage vor
dem flughafen
ausgeharrt praktisch ohne toilette ohne
regelmäßiges wasser zur verfügung zu
haben hat sich dann bei ihrer tante
wieder versteckt ich höre jetzt heute
dass eine hilfsorganisation die leute
noch zum flughafen gebracht hat sie
mitgenommen hat und dass sie jetzt auf
dem flughafen ist und jetzt die chance
hat das land zu verlassen aber das sind
eben immer einzelfälle und das große
problem ist wie viele die sich mit
afghanistan beschäftigen viele kollegen
auch ja versuchen alle noch irgendwie
einzelne menschen auf transporter zu
bekommen zum flughafen zu geleiten
irgendwie etwas für die zu erreichen
aber das hat natürlich keine systematik
es ist immer ein ein engagement für den
einzelfall der dann in diesem fall gut
ausgegangen ist ich habe einen anderen
fall haben wir eine familie über zehn
tage begleitet er ist mit drei kleinen
kindern sechs tage in folge an diesem
flughafen gewesen steht auf der
deutschen evakuierungs liste hat papiere
er hat immer wieder versucht an deutsche
soldaten heranzukommen er wurde von
amerikanern abgewiesen es gab kontakt
mit den deutschen behörden das ging
wirklich so weit dass er mit der rosa
strickjacke seines kindes in der menge
gewunken hat weil es eine absprache
gegeben hat dass man ihnen so erkennen
kann er hat uns dann schließlich eine
nachricht geschickt ich muss hier weg
aus dem flughafen weil wir werden hier
beschossen ich habe 2 meine kleinen
kinder hier verloren da war wirklich
verzweifelt dem ende hat er gesagt ich
versuche es vielleicht jetzt auf eigene
faust alleine weil mit einer familie
kommt man hier in diesem chaos nicht
durch und es gibt auch keine keine
sicheren perspektive
letztendlich hat es auch für ihn einen
ausweg gegeben der war sehr sehr
kompliziert das will ich jetzt hier gar
nicht im detail schildern in letzter
konsequenz muss man aber sagen das ist
nicht gut dass jeder einzelfall
irgendwie verhandelt durch gekämpft wird
und es immer noch keine systematischen
perspektiven für die menschen gibt die
auszureisen das sind auf der einen seite
ortskräfte das sind auch noch wenige
verbleibende deutsche aber das sind auch
eben noch so viele afghanische
menschenrechtler journalisten
sportlerinnen im alle die die für ein
modernes afghanistan eingetreten sind
die wir auch dazu ermuntert haben dafür
einzutreten
die nicht aus dem land kommen und die
jetzt ihr leben riskieren wenn sie
zurück bleiben zum schluss noch die
frage an sie herr assisi wir haben von
ihnen auch gehört das war mehr glück
dass sie es auch raus geschafft haben
werden da wenig hilfe erfahren welche
frage würden sie deutschen
verantwortlichen politikerinnen
politikern für
importe frage würden sie stellen also
was wäre was wäre ihrer meinung nach zu
tun
also eine gute organisation eine bessere
organisation und
besser organisieren einfach und die
duschen das was ich in den unnötigen
sagen möchten bitte geben sie mir eine
minute zeit wir wollen in zwei klassen
geteilt durch die deutsche botschaft
einmal gebürtige deutsche die echte
durch ein und einmal die reporterin kann
mir bestätigen einmal die durch ein wie
ich die tour de ski statt natürlichkeit
seit 40 jahre besitzer wir mussten alle
über nord geht auf eigene verantwortung
fahren und die echte die gebürtige
deutsche aber auch dort wo das taliban
die kontrolle auch vom flughafen wie
diplomatischen auto
sind sie rein gefahren wurden auf dem
lager als ich im lager statt ich habe
keinen deutschen gesehen auf einmal
standen viele frau und wirklich mit
westlicher klamotten ich habe dir fragt
ich bin auch durch ja und du bist du
bist wie bis zu gewonnen hatte hier
wurden alle über auto mit diplomatischen
auto rein gefahren die reporterin kann
mir bestätigen dass vor diesem not
bringt kein einziger gebürtiger
deutscher steht aber nun die aufgabe die
durch die stadt herne möglichkeit
besitzen aber in die in diese kategorie
gehören aber die echte durch ich weiß
ich nach dem nach dem grundgesetz sind
wir alle gleich aber da wurden wir mit
zwei anleihen maßen beendet und das hat
mich sehr bewegt und ich wollte einfach
mich an sie binden dass die zuständigen
im auswärtigen amt einfach dass sie
erfahren warum wir anders behandelt
werden als die gebürtige deutsche das
war wirklich auf dem herzen und ich war
sehr traurig sehr wirklich sehr dass die
deutschen mehr geholfen haben am
flughafen medizinisch und sowas bin ich
ihnen sehr dankbar und das verlange ich
auch das ist mein land und dass ich
hierher gekommen bin ich bin nicht
woanders gegangen ich bin in meinem land
zurück gekommen seit 40 jahren arbeite
ich hier und dann dass sie mit dass man
in zwei klasse behandelt dass ich hab's
23 tagen die ich geschlafen wird uns so
was passiert ist sagen sie reporterin
sie findet kein einzige blutige durch
hervorgeht über diesen entschuldigung ja
über diese komplizierte lage wäre raus
kommt und wer nicht wollen wir in dieser
sendung noch weiter sprechen aber an
dieser stelle würde ich mich zunächst
mal bei ihnen beiden bedanken danken
dass sie sich zeit genommen haben und
heute in der st danke danke schön da
könnt ich abend
also auch heute in berlin in der
regierungserklärung der kanzlerin gab es
eine äußerung ihrerseits zur situation
in afghanistan und bevor wir hier
weitermachen wollen wir hier mal kurz
reinhören
die entwicklungen der letzten tage sind
furchtbar sie sind bitter für viele
menschen in afghanistan sind sie eine
einzige tragödie ganz besonders für
diejenigen sich für eine freie
gesellschaft für demokratie und bildung
eingesetzt haben und die nun um ihre
sicherheit fürchten müssen wir alle
zusammen die wir in afghanistan
engagiert worden also die gesamte
internationale koalition
wir alle haben die geschwindigkeit
dieser entwicklung ganz offensichtlich
unterschätzt und das gilt auch für
deutschland
über die frage wie das jetzt alles
weitergehen soll und was da
schiefgelaufen ist möchten wir hier
jetzt gerne sprechen einmal mit um mit
nouripour außenpolitischer sprecher der
grünen und mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss und mit patrick sensburg
cdu-abgeordneter selbst oberst der
reserve und mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss guten abend
bevor ich mich den fragen von ihnen
beiden zuwende wenn du kurz ein kleiner
hinweis mit dem blick auf die kommentare
hier bei uns ich würde darum bitten dass
wir wirklich hier keinen platz für hass
und hetze in unseren kommentarspalten
haben und dazu aufrufen bitte sachlich
zu bleiben dass wir jetzt auch viele
konstruktive fragen gemeinsam besprechen
können also wir haben soeben die
kanzlerin gehört und vielleicht zunächst
mal die frage an sie beide auch die
frage unserer sendung ist das jetzt eine
situation lässt deutschland seine
ortskräfte da jetzt gerade irgendwo ein
stück weit auch im stich vielleicht
zuerst dazu herr sensburg ich glaube
erst mal muss man die worte der
kanzlerin wirklich ernst nehmen ist es
eine tragödie eine tragödie für das land
für alle die die sich dafür eingesetzt
haben dass afghanistan andere
perspektiven bekommt und wir tun sehr
viel wir tun sehr viel dass wir zum
einen sehr schnell unsere deutschen
bürgerinnen und bürger aus afghanistan
holen aber auch alle die mit uns
zusammengearbeitet haben und das ist gar
nicht einfach denn über die ortskräfte
und da verstehen wir auf die
sprachmittler darunter gibt es ja ganz
ganz viele die teilweise sehr intensiv
aber teilweise auch weniger intensiv
aber kontinuierlich mit der deutschen
bundes aber auch andy aus
zusammengearbeitet haben und da wirklich
jedem eine chance zu geben das land zu
verlassen jeden auch zu erfassen ist
unheimlich schwierig aber beispielsweise
die bundeswehr leistet dort unheimlich
viel deswegen möchte ich auch mal danke
sagen an die soldatinnen und soldaten
die unter schwersten bedingungen auch
jetzt da unten sind und wirklich eine
ganz tolle arbeit leisten herr nouripour
ihre ihre antwort auf die frage also
lässt deutschland seine ortskräfte da
gerade im stich wird von herrn sensburg
gerade gehört er sagt es gibt ja wohl
auch seiner meinung nach ja abstufungen
je nachdem wie lange vielleicht jemand
zusammengearbeitet hat wie sehen sie das
ich schließe mich 100 prozent
dem dank an angehörigen
helfen auch beim rest nix mehr ein eine
dieser
steht auch jetzt
wenn ich sein müssten wenn man ein tor
und jetzt eine komplett neue
mann
hat immer mal gesagt bei
goldbarren dann wird im sommer haben wir
noch die bundespolizei der bundespolizei
sowie kabul
dann sagte
dann kam die bilder und dann sagten
helfen der letzten 20 jahre jetzt hat
heute
heiraten aber was soll das denn sein
denn eigentlich machen wie verlässlich
sind jetzt in lebensgefahr
und was ist das wer verträge selbst hat
wundert was das problem ist
sich klas zulegen weil angst haben
irgendwelche leute
obwohl wir den
schutz bieten werden
und diese leute jetzt verlassen und
deshalb
herr nouripour ich muss man kurzer haft
die technik hinweisen ich habe sie
gerade hier sehr schlecht verstanden
vielleicht schreibt ihr in den
kommentaren auch mal wie es euch ging
nur vielleicht die kurze frage an sie
ihr gerät mit dem sie mit uns sprechen
ihr laptop vielleicht auf irgend was
drauf steht der den ton schlug
vielleicht könnten sie das kurz prüfen
und ich würde herrn sensburg schon mal
die erste frage aus dem stream stellen
und zwar möchte armin tun bei facebook
wissen von wie vielen orts- kräften
sprechen wir da eigentlich das ist eine
unheimlich gute frage denn da hängt eben
schon damit zusammen wie definieren wir
denn all sorts kraft orts kraft ist kein
feststehender begriff und das weiß
kollegin report ganz gut wir haben im
auswärtigen ausschuss wir haben im
verteidigungsausschuss und wir haben
auch in anderen ausschüssen intensiv
darüber gesprochen wer alles orts kraft
ist das sind eben nicht nur die die
intensiv mit der bundeswehr oder anderen
organisationen zusammengearbeitet haben
das sind eben auch zum beispiel die
wachleute die afghanische wachleute an
den liegenschaften das sind zum beispiel
auch die handwerker die für die
bundeswehr oder auch ngo ausgearbeitet
haben das sind viele andere und da
müssen wir uns auch gedanken machen
welche perspektiven können wird denen
geben wie gibt es möglicherweise auch
über den 31 august hinaus die
möglichkeit aus afghanistan auszureisen
und da denken wir schon gerade über
viele andere möglichkeiten von zivilen
flügen bis zur ausreise über land nach
das geht nicht überall aber da macht
sich die bundesregierung und wir alle
auch gedanken drüber alles viel zu spät
das ist richtig aber ich möchte den gern
sehen der vorher gewusst hat wie sich
alles entwickelt das haben wir eben war
ein doktor assisi gesehen selbst er war
hätte nicht gedacht dass dies alles so
schnell passiert dass die taliban so
schnell wohl vorbringen sie haben es
eben angesprochen also alles viel zu
spät was kann denn jetzt überhaupt noch
getan werden also gibt es irgendwie
pläne von deutscher seite vielleicht
auch den menschen den weg an den
flughafen zu leichter zu machen
also ich glaube dass es sehr schwer den
weg an den flughafen als einzige option
zu sehen wir haben gesehen in den
bildern und das hören wir aus allen
berichten wie umlagert der flughafen
bereits ist jeder weiß es geht um
stunden und wenige tage also wird es am
flughafen nicht leichter werden wir
werden schauen ob wir möglicherweise
weitere punkte im land identifizieren
können über die eine ausreise möglich
ist aber da bitte werde ich das jetzt
nicht hier live sagen das macht es den
menschen erheblich schwerer und
unsicherer dann das land zu verlassen
herr nouripour ich würde es gern noch
einmal kurz mit dem nun versuchen wir
können es jetzt nochmal miteinander
probieren vielleicht da jetzt auch eine
frage noch mal aus dem stream ansehen
und wir müssen schauen ob das jetzt beim
mit ihrem ton irgendwie besser geklappt
hat und zwar gab es hier die frage von
jamie sieg bei facebook was ist mit den
menschen die außerhalb von kabul leben
bei gesprächen ja tatsächlich die ganze
zeit immer nur über den weg über kabul
diese leute werden
spannend ich hoffe die
hoffnung macht also
13 es wird nur noch jeder mitmachen und
1 nachdem
alle anderen
aktionen natürlich
kommt auch dauere es
wird ein zaun
es tut mir wahnsinnig leid der empfang
ist zu schlecht wir werden das jetzt
noch mal versuchen zu klären so lange
werde ich mit herrn sensburg das
gespräch wird er finde ich hoffe dass
wir noch mal gegen eine bessere
verbindung zu ihnen kriegen aber ich
lese in den kommentaren es ist leider
nicht gut zu verstehen vielleicht klappt
das noch das würd mich freuen
dankeschön
sensburg vielleicht weil wir das jetzt
gerade nicht gut gehört haben die frage
an sie was es mit den menschen außerhalb
kabuls können sie dazu kurz vielleicht
das sagen also das ist wirklich eine
schwere situation
und herr nouripour so viel habe ich
zumindest gehört sagte er selbst hat
vielleicht geheiminformationen das habe
ich nicht wir wissen auch aus
medienberichten dass die bundeswehr mit
hilfe des ksk und zwei hubschraubern
versucht auch menschen die weiter
entfernt sind von kabul noch zu den
flügen zu bekommen wir wissen auch dass
journalisten andere wege gefunden haben
um aus dem land auszureisen es gibt
andere wege und wir denken natürlich
auch über die wege nach wer in anderen
landesteilen weit weg von kabul ist wie
es die möglichkeiten der ausreise gibt
also es gibt einmal die möglichkeit
jetzt in den nächsten tagen auszureisen
das wird nur ein kleiner teil der
menschen sein die die sorge haben von
den taliban verfolgt zu werden ich denke
gerade von denen ihn erwähnten kämpfern
für demokratie für menschenrechte für
frauenrechte es gibt eine
hochschulprofessoren dieses
hochschulrektorin da wird es natürlich
sicherlich nicht einfach gemacht werden
ihre aufgaben weiter wahrzunehmen auch
da müssen wir uns gedanken machen wir
können wir diesen menschen helfen das
geht weit über die ortskräfte hinaus und
das wird sehr schwer werden denn eines
muss uns klar sein die taliban haben die
macht in afghanistan übernommen das ist
eben ein fakt und das macht es uns allen
der gemeinschaft die hier helfen wollen
kein stück leichter und mit den taliban
zu verhandeln ist eben auch sehr
schwierig weil wir glaube ich das gefühl
haben auch diese generation der taliban
ist nicht besser sie werden genauso
gewalttätig sein sie werden genau solche
greueltaten begehen deswegen ist auch
sehr schwer hier abkommen einzugehen
aber in erster linie muss das leben der
menschen stehen ihr parteikollege und
der obmann des auswärtigen ausschusses
roderich kiesewetter sagte bei uns im
zdf um menschenleben zu retten müsse man
mit den taliban verhandeln wie sehen sie
das glauben sie dass das nicht möglich
sein sollte und das ist das was ich
gerade meinte menschenleben stehen an
erster stelle da müssen wir auch
kompromisse eingehen aber es darf eben
nicht so weit gehen dass wir den taliban
zu lasten anderer wieder zugeständnisse
machen zur unterdrückung von menschen im
land denn eins muss klar sein der größte
teil der bevölkerung auch diejenigen die
sich demokratischer strukturen erhofft
haben werden im land verbleiben und auch
über die müssen wir uns gedanken machen
auf diplomatischem wege weil die
militärische mission ist beendet aber
auch sie liegen uns am herzen
über die situation mit den taliban vor
ort in kabul die die checkpoints auf dem
weg zum flughafen kontrollieren wollen
uns jetzt im bericht anschauen von
meinem kollegen und wann kurschilgen
kein zweifel wer hier das kommando hat
taliban kämpfer sind allgegenwärtig auf
den straßen von kabul
sie kontrollieren das zentrum ihres
neuen regimes dass die islamische emirat
afghanistan nennen wollen
wir haben unsere führer wir haben unsere
nation wir haben ein ziel was auch immer
unsere führer sagen wir werden gehorchen
alle unsere mutter ideen brüder haben
eine stimme
eine reporterin vom französischen
fernsehen ist in kabul und berichtet
man kann nicht weit in die stadt
vordringen bevor man auf schwer
bewaffnete taliban-kämpfer stößt diese
männer sitzen in einem fahrzeug der
ehemaligen afghanischen polizei
jetzt sperren die taliban offenbar
straßen in kabul so wollen sie
verhindern dass noch mehr menschen zum
flughafen gelangen
die ordnung ist zurück in kabul es gibt
keine einbrüche mehr niemand darf ohne
erlaubnis ein haus betreten das ist
jetzt nach unserem gesetz verboten aber
wir sind nicht nachtragend wir vergeben
allen sogar militanten diese bilder
sprechen eine andere sprache taliban
verprügeln menschen am flughafen in
kabul
bevor wir auf die lage mit den taliban
zu sprechen kommen leider noch der
hinweis dass wir die verbindung zur omid
nouripour nicht mehr in einer guten ton
qualität aufbauen konnten ich habe auch
schon in den kommentaren gelesen die
frage warum wir so was nicht vorher
testen wir haben es natürlich vorher
getestet da hat es ganz gut geklungen
und jetzt gerade lässt es sich leider
für den moment nicht mehr lösen aber wir
wollen weiter sprechen mit herrn
sensburg wir haben gerade den bericht
gesehen über die aktuelle situation mit
den taliban in kabul und heute gab es
eben einen tweet auch vom
verhandlungsführer der aus deutschland
kirsch entsandt wurde marcus bosse der
geschrieben hat bei twitter dass die
taliban also nun zugesagt haben sollen
dass afghanen und afghaninnen auch nach
dem us truppenabzug das land verlassen
dürften auf zivilen flügen herr salzburg
ist dieser aussage zu trauen
ich glaube vertrauen würde ich hier auf
keinen fall man kann nicht sicher sein
welche gruppe der taliban gerade spricht
man kann auch nicht sicher sein ob das
eine mediale kampagne ist ich glaube die
taliban versuchen jetzt in einem ersten
schritt die kontrolle über das land und
insbesondere über die großen städte zu
bekommen sie versuchen auch zu zeigen
dass die kontrolle haben dass die
ordnung schaffen dass sie ja ein
moderates regime zumindest aus ihrer
sichtweise darstellen und ich glaube in
einem zweiten schritt wenn sie die
kontrolle haben wenn sie auf
namenslisten haben dann werden andere
saiten aufgezogen also ich vertraue
diesen taliban kein stück mehr als den
früheren generationen und von daher
müssen wir uns größte sorgen machen aber
wir können natürlich schauen dass wir
dieses zeitfenster in dem die taliban
auch jetzt gesagt haben dass sie
ausreisen ermöglichen dass sie visa auch
für zivile flüge ermöglichen dass wir
das nutzen aber mit der gewissheit das
wird mit sicherheit nicht eine politik
langfristiger art sein sondern wir
müssen jetzt schauen welche
möglichkeiten gibt es vielleicht auch
den flughafen kabul wieder vereinzelt
für zivile flüge zu öffnen um dann
möglichkeiten auch der ausreise mit visa
zu schaffen sie sprechen die
möglichkeiten an die vielleicht noch
bleiben also es gab auch ideen scheinbar
menschen vielleicht über den landweg
rauszubringen in den benachbarten
ländern ist das denn realistisch das ist
realistisch wenn ich natürlich in
landesteilen bin die nah an den grenzen
sind das ist nicht realistisch wenn ich
mitten im land bin oder wenn ich der
nähe von kabul bin der landweg ist
unheimlich er schwerlich in afghanistan
ist unsicher er führt durch
unterschiedliche regionen auch mit
unterschiedlichen machthabern also dass
es nichts was man empfehlen kann aber
wenn ich grenznah derzeit bin dann ist
das eine option die möglich ist man muss
jedweder option zur zeit nutzen um die
möglichkeit der ausreise zu haben weil
ich gehe davon aus dass die taliban
zeitnah andere saiten aufziehen und sie
haben ja auch schon gesagt die
intellektuellen sie sollen bitte nicht
alle das land verlassen ich glaube das
wort bitte wird relativ schnell aus dem
schwarz gestrichen werden und dann wird
es ein klares verbot und auch die
verfolgung andersdenkender geben es gibt
auch fragen im stream über jetzt die
aktuelle die aktuellen evakuierungsflüge
wie das abläuft und da gibt es zum einen
die frage von pretoria 72 bei youtube
wird eigentlich die kapazität des
flughafens und der flugzeuge inzwischen
voll ausgenutzt ich sehe da immer wieder
maschinen herum stehen geht da noch mehr
oder war das schon alles fragt er sich
also ich kann es nur aus deutscher seite
sagen dort werden alle kapazitäten
ausgenutzt aber es muss natürlich auch
die sicherheit vorhanden sein die
sicherheit einen sicheren start machen
zu können eine sichere landung machen zu
können es muss die sicherheit da sein
ein flugzeug auch richtig beladen zu
können natürlich mit passagieren an
erster stelle aber es muss dann auch
irgendwann wieder abfliegen können wenn
es betankt ist darf es eben gerade gar
nicht lange stehen und von daher all
diese verschiedenen parameter müssen
berücksichtigt werden und da kann es
auch mal sein dass vielleicht nicht der
letzte platz einer maschine aus genutzt
ist und dann kann es eben auch mal sein
dass eine maschine später reinkommt oder
früher rein kommt also keiner möchte
hier leere maschinen oder halb leere
maschinen starten lassen wir versuchen
wirklich alles um diese mission so
effizient wie möglich auch wirklich
vonstatten gehen zu lassen uns ist das
ziel wirklich ganz klar hier die
menschen zu retten aus dieser schweren
situation wie es die kanzlerin heute
gesagt hat wir haben am anfang unserer
sendung sehr eindrücklich gehört was das
derzeit für ein chaos dort vor ort ist
und dass eben auch schon seit mehreren
tagen war das denn ein fehler dass man
im vorfeld vielleicht auch nicht klarer
gemacht hat von deutscher seite wer raus
kommt und wenn nicht ja ich glaube der
fehler lag darin dass man nicht erkannt
hatte wie schnell es gehen wird das
nicht nur die taliban das hinterland
besetzen die fläche sondern auch die
großen städte insbesondere kabul was man
nicht erkannt hat ist dass die
afghanische armee nicht kämpfen wird
sondern quasi fast ohne gefecht das
ganze land aufgibt weil sie gesagt hat
für diese regierung für diese
regierenden kämpfen wir nicht riskieren
wir nicht unser leben das hätte man
vielleicht erkennen können wie man auch
mehr mit den soldatinnen und soldaten
gesprochen hätte die da erfahrungen
haben wir haben es aber alle wohl so
nicht erkannt dass muss man sagen und
wir sollten auch unsere schlüssel zum
beispiel für andere missionen daraus
ziehen in anderen ländern darf uns das
nicht noch einmal passieren ich denke
jetzt an die diskussion beispielsweise
in mali dort haben wir übrigens auch
ortskräfte
jetzt geht es ja gerade noch um diese
aktuelle situation da vor ort die alles
andere als reibungslos läuft und da
vielleicht auch die frage also die
deutsche truppe vor ort scheint ja jetzt
nicht in der lage dazu zu sein wie die
anderen auch die internationalen truppen
ohne die amerikanische hilfe also diese
evakuierung sicherzustellen und die es
eben mal zu ende und da vielleicht auch
ein bisschen die frage ist da zu wenig
koordination am boden zwischen den
internationalen truppen was läuft schief
es ist nicht die koordination es ist
dass wir die amerikaner brauchen um auch
den flughafen zu sichern diese hohe zahl
an soldatinnen und soldaten haben wir
nicht in afghanistan hat die
völkergemeinschaft insgesamt nicht in
afghanistan und wir werden nicht darüber
reden ob wir die bundeswehr in einem so
großen umfang alleine nach afghanistan
schicken um den flughafen zu sichern da
habe ich noch keine stimme in diese
richtung gehört also in einer koalition
brauche es die verschiedenen
truppensteller da sind die amerikaner
immer noch der größte und die die am
meisten last tragen und die amerikaner
haben klagt wert dass sie bis zum 31
august den flughafen verlassen das land
verlassen von daher ist das eine
rahmenbedingungen die die deutsche
bundeswehr vorfindet gegen die sie so
auch nichts machen kann die amerikaner
sind sehr schnell aus dem land heraus
das hat uns alle auch überrascht das hat
auch dazu beigetragen dass die
afghanischen kräfte nicht gekämpft haben
weil sie sich verlassen und im stich
gelassen gefühlt haben aber wir finden
diese situation vor und wir versuchen in
diesem rahmen alles menschenmögliche zu
leisten um diejenigen die jetzt noch am
flughafen sind herauszubekommen und da
leisten unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
fast rund um die uhr teilweise ohne
schlaf wirklich eine beachtliche aufgabe
die frage zum schluss mit einer bitte
auch im nur kurze antwort vielleicht was
ist ihre prognose jetzt für die für die
nächsten tage bleibt es bei diesem chaos
es wird nicht leichter werden in und um
den flughafen in kabul ich befürchte es
wird sogar schwerer werden weil die
hoffnung bei manchen menschen dazu führt
dass eben auch noch zum flughafen gehen
es wird aber hoffentlich auch über den
august noch möglichkeiten geben dass
menschen das land verlassen und diese
möglichkeiten sollten wir in der
vielfalt alle auch wenn es nur
einzelfälle sind wie eben gesagt worden
ist alle nutzen um jedweden zu retten
der zu retten ist
vielen dank an patrick sensburg cdu
abgeordneter und mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss danke ihnen
und auch vielen dank an omid nouripour
der uns am anfang der sendung
zugeschaltet war leider gab es eben nur
sehr wenig zeit den ton zu testen und so
und die hoffnung dass wir in den
nächsten tagen auch noch einmal dazu
kommen mit omid nouripour zu sprechen an
dieser stelle auch danke an eure
aufmerksamkeit und die fragen und wir
bleiben natürlich am thema weiter dran
bis dahin tschüss